[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as I'm checking my Instagram I'm getting
this Eagle propaganda and I don't want
to hear it but we are here we are here
because it is the uh it's the conference
championships conference championships
rounds we're here uh Sam
I know you got a big Niners Futures bet
I don't even want to hear what Ryan has
to say right now because I also have a
Niners future I also have it yeah but
yeah Brian the focus is on Sam Sam talk
to us how you feeling today
I I feel good I I will say this like I I
said it when I took the bet I said it
before last week I'll still say I think
the Niners are the best team in the
league I know people don't necessarily
agree I've been really surprised Greg
that this line has trended so much
towards Philadelphia it's now
Philadelphia minus three I think we're
seeing some recency bias because yeah I
feel you got to play a poverty team last
week in the Giants and the Niners had to
play a really good Cowboys team so I I
think that has changed everything
recency bias East Coast bias I call it
same like it's the same thing and Brian
what are you talking about the Cowboys
are not good you just last week you were
sitting here telling us how good they
were and how they were going to beat the
Niners when the Cowboys get in the
divisional round and I don't know if you
guys know this but there's Sam likes to
talk about dboa I like to talk about 27
years of History they turn to [__] and
every single year they make a family
show
yeah I know I'm hot I know you guys you
got me all riled up before the show
apologies but they do 27 years of not
winning that game they go into San
Francisco Santa Clara wherever the hell
in California this is Sacramento maybe
who knows and they look you guys
struggle to beat a Cowboys team that
can't win that game their defense is
number two in the league what are we
even talking about regular season
amazing against Tampa they look so good
with the poverty team Tampa's apartment
what sample size what sample size are
you going off of what sample size
one week take the divisional round of
every single Cowboy season
your entire evaluation of the Cowboy
season is just based on last week so
nothing else matters yes it's a failure
it's a failure I'm worried about you I'm
so worried about you because just last
week just last week and you claimed to
be a man of the people you were telling
these people that's tuning into us to
bet the Cowboys and that they were a
good team but now today it's a new day
new Sunday you're in here talking about
the Cowboys are not a good team well
yeah listen mistakes were made last
weekend
he's a broken man he's a broken man hey
welcome to the show everybody man we got
to get started my name is Greg Ivory
next to me is the man I like to call the
man the myth the legend Sam Richmond and
next to him is uh
Ryan I don't even know if you deserve a
introduction today because like
you're a Cowboys fan
yeah
and I saw on social media you guys can
go check us out BR betting on on Twitter
Instagram Tick Tock I saw on social
media what you were doing brother and
I'm I'm nervous like I'm I'm confused
not nervous but I'm more so confused and
concerned
yeah why don't you tell the people what
you're wearing today Ryan oh my God that
is disgusting
Greg would you ever in a million years
wear LA Dodgers hat no you no you
couldn't pay me any money to where a
Dodger hat I'm not wearing it
I'm not worried I'm believing in God and
God's going to find another way that I
can make money and I'm not wearing the
Dodger hat Brian wearing that makes me
feel better about San Francisco today
absolutely okay wow
yeah okay we got 30 minutes left in the
show and that's how we're gonna start it
awesome cool uh
I have no intent I never claimed to be a
man of integrity right I said to be a
man of my word I never said a man of
integrity so I can be bought I will say
that hey you know why we're here guys
everybody know why we are here uh to
build a parlay in today's extra special
because we are building two parlays and
that's one for each game so let's kick
it off with the game of the day I think
the game of the day the game of the
century
oh I got the sweatshirt on uh Niners
Eagles
let's get right to it uh Sam you
mentioned you mentioned before the show
just give you guys a little preset
before the show Sam mentioned we got to
get Debo in here
some way somehow we gotta get Debo in
here so Ryan
if you want to go look at Debo's numbers
yeah I'm responding to some chat right
now
let's not do the show Ryan just you know
respond to your haters in the chat um
do we not respond to our audience we do
verbally not you messaging them back in
the chat
um
I will say this I do you know obviously
I'm a big believer in this Niners team
uh like I said I I think they win today
I think this line is out of hand I think
two offensive Playmakers I think are
really going to have to be special today
I mean nothing too crazy but I think
it's going to be kiddle obviously he has
a really strong rapport with Brock Purdy
we saw that last week even that Circus
catch he seemed super locked in and I
also think we're going to see a lot of
Debo work I think this is where Kyle
Shanahan is going to get Super Creative
he knows it's Eagles defense is fast he
knows that he wants to take the pressure
off Purdy so I think you're going to see
Debo getting handoffs screens end
arounds everything so I I my if we're
looking at Pro Niners props I would
throw out Debo and Kittle but I'm Chris
what you guys say and I'm curious what
the chat says I love that Sam I love
that uh we're still going touchdown
parlays right or are we mixing it up
we're open for anything here we're open
for anything here so we could we could
throw in a little rush yards a little
receiving yards Ryan go look at his
restaurant I took it uh
I took it what was that what was it the
first round of the playoffs I think or
the second round I forget oh no we were
in England yeah yeah yeah yeah at 21 and
a half
[Music]
I will say this I because of the big
division between you know who we think
is going to win the game I don't think
in these parlays we should have money
lines or spreads I think we should just
stick with player props well what I was
going to propose and
okay I'm trying to figure out the the
chat is on Debo the chat's on AJ it
seems like a big it seems like a big uh
in all honesty I I think AJ AJ AJ
Brown's gonna he's gonna he's gonna have
a good game
I think he's gonna have a good game I
think the Niners can limit him though
but
yeah I mean if you're if you're looking
at this game I think the place of the
Eagles have the biggest Edge on the
night or the Niners biggest weakness I
think everyone would say is they
struggled defending the the Deep ball
and that's where aj Brown and Devonte
Smith are really dangerous and I think I
wouldn't be surprised if they try and
get AJ Brown involved early and often
just especially with some of the stuff
that's happened the last few weeks I I
think they want to keep him happy so uh
I don't hate that at all I think dbj
Brown is a good start
on the on the uh point of picking sides
do we not think that like Eagles plus
four and a half
is a lock no because I'm not going to
root for that at all and I want to know
okay I mean but that would be they can
lose by four and you could still win
I think we should I think let's let's
lock in our first two player props
um and then if we want to have that
discussion we can hey Ryan this isn't
your parlay that's true that's a good
take
assembled okay all right so what do we
what do we like here for Debo
do you want to do you want to do 15 plus
I gotta bite my tongue Debo 15 plus
Debo 15 plus I feel like that's a lock
like for Russia yeah I think D bro
they're gonna the Jet Sweep they're
gonna put them in the backfield he's
going to be all over the place today
it's going to be a bloodbath out there
in Philadelphia it's going to be a line
of scrimmage game
and that's where bibos performs there's
a lot of AJ Brown Love in the chat a lot
of yeah
I see some uh from Zibby Devonta over
five and a half receptions uh bar hey
Elijah Mitchell rushing yards I do see
AJ Brown love so uh the onions back in
here saying Boston Scott TD for the fun
that is like
that's nightmare Vibes because every
time his body scores but I don't know if
we can I let's just let's throw in Debo
15 plus as a placeholder and move over
to AJ Brown
good job Sam if we want to change it we
can
so I do agree with the Chad I do think
like I said I do think we're gonna get a
lot of a lot of AJ so Bill Bay said he
likes that giving us fire emojis so uh
let's move on
do you guys think that AJ Brown and I
would like the chats take as well we
could do one of three things take his
anytime touchdown take some yards or my
preference would be to take an ALT
receptions but juice it from the
original line I think he's gonna catch a
ton of balls today
I'm fine with I'm fine with either those
options so I would I would defer to Greg
or the chat if they if they have any
takes
propaganda
no I'm not you Ryan I am a man of the
people
I will push the people
all right uh the reason
yards might be the move is again because
the Niners are vulnerable on the Deep
ball so you might be able to get 40 you
know 40 yards off one play here to be
honest I like yards and receptions for
AJ brown but I do understand where
you're coming from Sam would like being
susceptible to the Deep ball that could
be you can get these yards in one play
you know what I'm saying
so do we like and the chat agrees it's
yards uh
also bagel and locks in here can we get
an adjusted total adjusted total like
40ish the lowest we can go is 60.
40. I think he's talking about the game
total I think he's talking about like an
actual game total yeah all right sorry
I'm uh you know okay bagel and locks is
always is always on the the front lines
of my
you know whatever uh so do we want to do
do we want to do 80 plus uh yards
that's not bad especially since we only
have three legs to work with I mean I
guess we could do more but I Envision it
being a three-legger since we have two
games to get two uh we do probably want
something in here that can get us decent
odds so I I don't hate that move yeah
oh sure I like it I mean yeah I like
that the kettle Purdy Connection in the
Red Zone has been is is lethal is their
connection is lethal right now that's
what I think that's how I think they're
gonna score I think it's either gonna be
like Debo rushes or Purdy to Kittle yeah
like that's that's pretty that's I like
that bro
that's pretty good here it is Ryan takes
from the chat
yeah
this is what I do uh
Ritter yes Ryan producer Ryan's back it
seems like producer Ryan's back
um
someone commented in the first two
minutes I used to like producer Ryan
which I thought was a very mean comment
and I was going to keep that's what I
was responding to
okay yeah I
I also you know I respond to my haters
every now and again too but I show them
love that's the problem
uh no no that's not there's no problem
with showing the haters love bro you
gotta show the haters love
I know I just want to wrap everyone in
my arms and just let them know it's
gonna be okay
should we do a thumbs up thumbs down
with this parlay in the chat
do we like this
no we should just watch it
I I think yeah let's yeah no let's do
thumbs up thumbs down because this is
this is the final this is the final
thing uh also I see bath Ave boy
dropping Scoops he's got nine oh kiddo's
got nine straight games of
all right uh okay thumbs up or thumbs
down I would say
on the party
we're rocking with you I like it Ryan
getting Ryan getting in some unfortunate
love for the Eagles hat which is tough
not realizing that I'm wearing a hat
from the NFL Ed Sheeran collection
um which is obviously a much better hat
so you know just just wait until the
chat sees what else I have online store
oh it's gonna be
this is going to be incredible all right
and we've got three two one asked what's
the lay it's on the screen
[Laughter]
can we getting some thumbs up I mean so
like I'm ready to put my foot down like
yeah yeah I think I think we should wrap
with it I think we should react with it
yeah we do I want to just uh shine light
on one comment here before we move on
from
crm6589 who uh is predicting a Kyle
juice uh a juice touchdown I'm not gonna
try to pronounce this last name
I like that but I'm not putting it on
the parlay yeah I know I know but we all
know that that's already gonna be the
first touchdown that's he will probably
be the first touchdown scorer and then
yeah that's not that's not bad yeah that
honestly not bad
um but all right we can't we can't risk
it on a fullback all right so this is
our first parlay but stay with us if you
don't like this lay we're making another
one right now we've got another lay
coming so got another lay coming we're
going to the next one
we're going to the next game the ladder
game Bengals Chiefs
it's a close one
the spread's close
uh how we feeling about this one fellas
Travis Kelsey I did see a Travis Kelsey
in the comments
um but talk to me which way what are you
guys thinking
I love
Patrick Mahomes today I think two plus
passing touchdowns easy
I'll say this about this game I
I'm not betting this game because I have
my life on the line in the first game
now if the Niners win this game then I
will potentially pick myself back up and
bet this game
um I like the Mahomes over props I I
like to choose in this game I do think
Mahomes is
oh I mean he's definitely limited but I
don't think he's as limited as we
thought he would be
um and at home at Arrowhead I I like
Mahomes I like the juice today so I'm
I'm with you for if we're looking at
some some Pat some Patty Mayo props
yeah we saw we saw them throughout the
week
no limp and practice no limp at the
podium I know they shot him up with
something in that leg so uh I like Pat
today I think he could go get two
touchdowns against that defense
I when I dropped two plus touchdowns I
mean
I had bet it earlier over one and a half
at minus 170 and now we're at minus 260.
so am I sharp I might be but I this was
not the value
right who's to say I mean eight and
three on the Best Bets who is to say
really but I thought it was ten and one
maybe I've got it wrong no I mean two of
them shouldn't count you're right
honestly all three of them shouldn't
count but I'm I'm humble
we should take a look at the Bengals
receiving Corps I'm seeing it in the
comments uh we got D Brown says Chase
over and I also seen T Higgins Trevor
Suite 11 Chi Higgins receptions uh that
Chief's defense is
they're not like you know they're not no
Niners defense they're not no Eagles
defense no they're I mean at this state
like they're an average defense so
they're in my mind a poverty defense at
this stage of the stage of the Season
can I propose something and and the chat
we've got a few people telling us that
uh Kelsey's got some back issues so he
might not be 100
um I I don't I don't know if I buy that
I think it's been fine yeah
on the on the subject of a tight end
though I as the as the self-proclaimed
uh tight end Guru
um you know attendee of tidan University
I love
Hayden Hurst to score a touchdown he but
he actually is hurt though
yeah but that doesn't matter because
this is my agenda okay fair
um I'm trying to look up the latest
update but like he actually is kind of
hurt
so yeah I mean uh he'll pay Ryan but
what's up I mean go ahead go ahead I
mean I wanted to touch on Joe burrow
before we went to hate and hers but
go ahead run your propaganda
no no no that was it that's good I'm
good okay well let's hold
out let's pull the Hayden Hurst from The
Parlor
I saw something we have no indication
from the chat that they like that
bad hate boy bad hey boy says burrow
owns Mahone's fellow Burrows two
touchdowns and and and the odds was
better than Pat Mahomes and we just
talked about that Chief's defense
I mean we could do both I'm not that's
right why can't we do that yeah that's
not bad
the only problem is it's like we've got
to get juice
we're also by doing this we're
subconsciously betting on the over so
like
I don't know I don't know it's like
these two picks are plus 115 right now
that's not bad throw on it anytime TV
and we're probably in that plus 500
range yes
but
yeah
ah Sam I don't know if I hated hers but
Merwin
well now let's go back to the anytime TD
um
trap where it says Hayden has a slight
calf injury thank you for the uh you
know what I will say about the chat
today which I maybe this is just me but
I feel like there's there's been a
decent amount of disagreement with our
picks but they also aren't suggesting a
ton of picks in the chat so drop your
pit like Drop what you want to see in
this parlay and we'll consider it the
only the only people I think are
dropping picks right now are I see a lot
of ques Watkins love but other than that
you know that's just score prediction so
if you like if you have a lay leg that
you want in this drop it in
um
does it feel wrong and this is me
suggesting a swap for the burrow leg uh
to not have Jamar Chase in here
and and so what are you suggesting he
has played very well against Kansas City
I will say no he has I think he's gonna
have uh many much yards
a lot I'm I'm down to go look uh yeah
let's go take a look let's have a good
look
uh
hhwg123 Chase anytime touchdowns D Brown
378 Chase over uh
Chase is getting a lot of love trevaine
James Chase touchdale
mixing over 60 yards a lot yeah a lot of
love for Chase 60 plus all right now
people are bringing bringing picks all
right love they're bringing the heat
they're bringing the heat a lot of Chase
love yeah let's look at some a lot of
Chase love
okay
100 plus
and and removing burrow or yeah or
adding to this
no no we're moving bro
I'm not opposed to that I'm not opposed
to that
all right I thought you liked odds but I
don't
that's as juicy as I thought it probably
because they're all connected well yeah
that's what I'm saying
my thing is I thought you're all you're
like a big juice guy right
Joe's not orange but I'm a big apple
juice guy
yeah
big apple juice so but Joe burrow Joe
burrow odds is
less than Patrick Mahomes
yeah but Patrick Mahomes is a lock my
eyes
you don't think Joe Barrel is to get to
no because I can see here's the problem
is I can see his joke
I could just see the the Bengals getting
into the Red Zone uh potentially The
Dead Zone as Sam would say and handing
it off too the dead zone is when you
have first single from between the eight
and the ten yard line that's a dead zone
yes because you settle for a field goal
in that spot right but I can also just
see them handing it off to Joe Mixon and
samaji pyrene where I I like Isaiah
Pacheco I think it's a it's a cute it's
a little fun story you know it's
adorable but he's not like
the Chiefs are trying to score it's
gonna be patent throwing the ball Miguel
leacha threw out a really interesting
one especially in light of the mom's
injury over nine and a half Mahomes
rushing yards that I mean that's I mean
that is so risky
you don't know if you can move
yeah
I would guarantee numbers I
doesn't that number feel insanely high
for him not being able to move
where is that I feel like so you're
thinking under wow they actually no I'm
thinking over
that's interesting nine plus oh it
doesn't do what I want it to do though
God damn it
someone says
all right yeah
we could do we could do all right let's
do this then let's see if this let's see
if this does what we wanted to do here
I'll play this game with you Greg I'll
do this song and dance all right
there it is
do we feel better because it's similar
odds do we feel better doing Jamar Chase
anytime touchdown instead of Jamar Chase
100 plus
yes
yes cool I think so I think I think he's
more likely to score a touchdown
than he is to get
a hundred yards but that's actually
that's a really good question like for
the chat I think as well
somebody says take my homes out put
Travis two plus TDS I don't know about
that yeah plus 285 though I do we like
does it have to be do we have to do
three legs like does it because
bad half boy says Pacheco 50 plus and 9
out of 10 games including 66 against
Cincy this year that's that's an
interesting stat
s Pacheco what so Chaco is 50 plus and
nine out of 10 games this year including
66 against Cincinnati it's an
interesting stat
it is an interesting stat I also seeing
a lot of T Higgins touchdown love
we have a lot of plays for this game
that we've been trying to figure out
what we do I feel like I feel like the
other game we felt very confident about
in this one I feel like we're we're all
over the place we need to we need to
Center ourselves I agree
all right Pacheco okay so if we did if
we did Pacheco over 44 and a half then
I don't like that
I don't like that it seems good about
the Mahomes rush yards it's like funny
but like I just I we don't know if you
can move yeah
Jay beer keeps my best sound but Jay
beer keeps dropping this and it's in
like
it's considerate we got he says P rind
is two and a half perceptions he's their
check down guy
like I'm gonna look it up Ryan you look
it up you look up the odds I'm gonna
look up his numbers
it's receptions numbers in the last
couple games
I I don't hate this is just I don't know
we'll say this
I will say this I actually think
we should keep the Pacheco leg
especially because like like I said I do
think my homes is generally speaking
okay but I wouldn't be surprised if
they're have to lean on the ground game
just a little bit more than usual
there's a little bit more than usual and
I think that does lend itself to a
checker he had five receptions last game
I'm just saying Bagel unlocks also said
and I agree with this that the borough
passing touchdowns and Bengals anytime
TD is messing with the juice I would be
okay yeah so what if we did we kept
Isaiah Pacheco in here we went back to
chase yards because I feel like we have
to have Jamar Chase in here and then the
chat is loving T Higgins anytime
touchdown
that's one person I'm fine with that
I'm fine with that you think it's one
you think it's one person Greg I've seen
one person say t Higgins touchdown but
run your PR go ahead run the play
run the play good play I I score a lot
of touchdowns running this play
that's debatable
that's too high
that's two yeah we could do what does
like 69 plus do yeah that's like same I
think that's the same that's like pretty
good it comes down to
okay all right we can always wrap this
probably up no no let's do that let's do
the 69 and a half what if we did 79 and
we bumped and we bumped Pacheco down to
34 and a half
I was gonna say I like the Pacheco and
Chase overs and then I think let's go
back and let's lock in in anytime TD
okay so Deuce I think Greg is right
there actually isn't that much Higgins
love there's not that much
and no they're saying no yeah there's a
lot of no for tea no no okay so let's
keep those two in so those are locked
we're gonna do checkout and Chase and
then let's figure out the anytime TD
strategy
in there I mean you know
It's Not a Bad Bet
yeah the juice just doesn't get there
but we could if we could move Chase to
like 79 and a half or whatever
yeah
all right Jake haters
rarely let you push or push your
propaganda
I know I mean should I let the chat
decide should we let the chat decide if
Ryan can push his propaganda today
I think I think it's time I think it's
time the chat lets me cook on my tight
ends
so so everybody y'all put thumbs up
thumbs down on haydenhurst getting added
to our parlays it's gonna get cooked man
ever when we put Kelsey in there I'm
saying Kelsey ATD Kelsey ATD Kelsey feel
better now we're getting somewhere
I see samaji at plus 500 but that's
bagel and lox so you know I ate in
herself he didn't hurt yeah
toned pizza or is that oh tone peas uh
oh Ryan eating hers
I think you think you might uh oh stop
no
that's only two people oh man
thumbs down
I think you take out hers you put in
Kelsey you bump up Chase to like 79 89
and a half that'll get us to like the
400 500 range and I think we'll feel
good about it well I think we'll feel
good about that
that's my job
there it is sorry Ryan I tried I I
actually tried yeah Craig did try for
you I actually tried to be 89 and a half
yeah like to me I feel like that's
that's pretty damn good there goes Ryan
I'm fine I'm fine with either 89.5 or 99
and a half I think but I think this is
the structure
oh McKinnon
yeah I would be down for that if we want
to do that instead of Kelsey
I'm done I'm fine with that oh this is
gonna get juicy if we do that but then I
think then I think I want to bump chase
down to a better place I like being in
the 500 range I agree I agree there's no
reason to risk it don't risk it no
biscuit though so I mean that's also
that's also a play uh okay yeah like
that's pretty good there it is here it
is all right let's ask the people let's
ask people you guys like this thumbs up
thumbs down
we kind of have to call it
all right yeah
we're not getting
okay Alex
2r14 says no
and a thumbs down appreciate that I
always appreciate the the feedback
without a solution that's always great
yeah well we do say put thumbs up or
thumbs down to be fair
that's true yeah yeah yeah that's okay
okay all right um
I will say I do think well okay now
we're starting to get some thumbs up oh
y'all see those thumbs UPS
y'all see those thumbs UPS I do think
the chat would be more in
to Kelsey
not saying we have to go back there Sam
I liked it
The Vibes hey hey if you guys are in
if you guys like this I'm we got a lot
of thumbs up too
here's the deal with it also we have the
uh the Pacheco stat that uh bath Ave boy
dropped which is feel good about uh
because if it loses I'll be in his deal
with someone else yes yes of course
right exactly that is his that's that's
his leg then we have the over 79 and a
half Chase receiving yards which I feel
like
I mean the 99 and a half was like I
think he's gonna have a day so I think
we all felt good about but over 79 and a
half that's going to be easy we might
cash out in the first quarter jerich
McKinnon is the only thing that we're
worried about I got I'm sorry there's so
much Kelsey love in the chat
go ahead Sam it's a lot of Kelsey love I
think I think you know we should make a
decision I think we'd throw Kelsey back
at it we give the chat one more minute
to react and if we I like I just we I
think we've got the you know the chat
has got us here they've given us great
stats there's so much Kelsey love
no I agree uh yeah right I think we
could bet we could bet McKinnon
separately but I think that the chat is
just you know they've been with us all
season
I'll be betting Hayden her separately
they said please guys listen to the
people let us choose
we're listening to the people hey we're
doing it we're doing it my biggest yeah
our biggest flaws we listen too much to
the people I think yeah not sometimes
all right the chat is the chat is about
to go crazy I think now that Kelsey's
back in there so
um I think I think that I think that's
it I think we go with that unless you
know let's put our foot down like let's
put our foot down we got to get out of
here soon too uh
all right
awesome thumbs up I see thumbs up Kelsey
easy I like it Michael reader thumbs up
Sherman thumbs up uh bagel and locks I
like it Zippy thumbs up yeah we're gonna
call it we're gonna call it Ryan tell
the people uh Ryan actually what are we
locking in what are we locking in all
right so uh s Riley says Ryan please
change hats I won't
um you need a sharing Hat Man
uh maybe maybe that'll get one of my
teams to actually win something
significant who knows um whatever don't
get me started uh okay so the first game
because people are asking about the
first game this is the this is the the
first parlay we have 15 plus rushing
yards for Debo Samuel
80 plus receiving yards for AJ Brown and
then in any time touchdown for the man
himself tight end University George
Kittle Plus 575.
love it there it is easy there it is
there it is
Easy Screenshot it screenshot it hold on
hold on ready you ready you ready
screenshot it there you go
now okay second game three like parlay
Isaiah Pacheco the bath Ave boy leg
Isaiah Pacheco over 44 and a half
rushing yards boom Jamar Chase over 99
and a half receiving yards it's a three
leg the Ryan leg
wouldn't go that far wouldn't go that
far but if that that helps you out sure
uh over 99 98 99 and a half receiving
yards for Jamar Chase and then the last
leg
Travis Kelsey to do what he does anytime
touchdown three legs plus 525 ready
screenshots screen screenshot screenshot
screenshot it don't ask us again what
the parlay is screenshot it screenshot
it yup there it is I like it good I feel
good already nut it out here I like
these layers hey Ryan also also you like
tight ends you are the tight end whisper
guess what we got two tight end
touchdown scores in our parlays so I
mean how are you feeling that's true
uh the other one should have been Hayden
Hurst which I will bet separately in a
few moments here but uh I feel pretty
good about this
all right Ryan's locked in uh
make sure you guys tell us on DraftKings
so you can get rich with us and it
wouldn't be right if we didn't do a
little anytime touchdown boost magic so
we're also going to boost my man CMC
Christian McCaffrey from minus 140 to
plus 150 he needs to get in that end
zone I want to see it now it's time for
our Best Bets
we have a fraud here
and I want everybody to identify the
fraud in the chat just go ahead call
them whatever you want he has many names
he has many names we have a fraud here
so I'm going to let the fraud go first I
think you only go by Sam don't you
go by the man the myth the Legends
whatever Guru
no no no no no no no no hold on hold on
Sam go first
so like I said I am not betting this
game but that's just because or any
games today because I have look at you
know my life on the line where the San
Francisco 49ers winning the Super Bowl
so I have a few I have two Futures on
them I would still take it if you don't
know if you tried still take it today I
think they're like plus 3 30.
um I think that's good value I think
they I think this is their toughest game
I I feel very comfortable about how they
match up in the Super Bowl
um versus a hobby of Mahomes or the
Cincinnati Bengals
um but yeah I I like the Niners to
advance today I think they've been the
best team in the league since they've
got Christian McCaffrey I know how good
the Eagles are but I do think we're
overreacting like I said the start of
the show to what the Eagles did to a
poverty Giants team I think I think
we're talking about this game
differently
if the Eagles had played a real opponent
last week and they're going to have
their hands full today and I will say
this before I give the microwave
everyone keeps talking about how good
the Eagles pass defense is and how much
Brock Purdy is going to suffer
struggle the Niners pass offense has
been the number one pass offense in
dvoix since rock party
everyone's predicting that downfall
we're gonna do this every week we've
done it every week's party oh he's gonna
this is the week he's gonna not do it
this is the week he's gonna struggle he
keeps playing ball I think he does it
again today
talk to him Sam I'm right there behind
you I'll go I'll go because the Fraud's
gonna go last but I'm going Niners money
line Sam just said it Sam just said it
you just said everything we needed to
say I think it's going to come down to
the front seven I think this game is
going to come down to the front seven
who's going to be more physical up front
and I feel like the 49ers are going to
be more physical upfront their
linebacking court is by far way better
than the Eagles
the offensive line
debatable defensive line debatable but
that linebacking course is way better
running backs way better I think this is
going to be a game in the trenches and
it's going to be a running running real
physical type Run game time of
possession type of game and the Niners
have the edge in running backs
also quarterbacks let's talk about it
Sam you mentioned it
I'm going to say it Brock Purdy is going
to perform today he's going to perform
Sam you said it the Niners the number
one right did you say number one number
one number one since he took over that's
better than Jalen hurts Brock Purdy is
better than Jalen hurts I'm saying it
right now Brock Purdy is better than
Jalen hurts
I don't I will say this too
I will say this too Greg on like the
pretty hurt stuff everyone's like Purdy
has no experience in big big games this
like hurts his this is her third playoff
game of his life
Tom Brady he's no Aaron Rodgers he's no
he's no veteran like veteran quarterback
that's been here before they're they're
dating they're the same like rock pretty
got two two uh two starts in the uh
postseason Jason Hurst don't have that
many more
I I listen I hate the fact that I
actually genuinely disagree with you
both here like I I the fact that you are
making me side on the side of
Philadelphia is actually disgusting I
have no idea how you could say Brock
Purdy is a better quarterback than Jalen
hurts and start pushing his number
experience I I the playoff experience
doesn't matter when you have a
significantly better team
how are they significant they're not
significantly better they're not
technically better oh if we want to play
that we're are we playing the games of
how how many games did they win during
the regular season because I think they
won 14.
have been the best team in the league
since they've gotten Christian McCaffrey
okay
exactly today's gonna be a Fred Warner
Dre Greenlaw Master Class there are some
actually breaking news that is actually
unfortunate Elijah Mitchell is out today
so Kevin Coleman Master Class
um yeah that actually is tough that
actually is tough
um
that's why we put Debo in the Park oh go
back to the parlay Ryan Ryan
just think about it just think about it
take a second just think who am I
thinking about who am I thinking about
no Elijah Mitchell
yeah Jordan racing
I love it got that separately okay we
gave we gave these two clowns uh ample
time to talk about their their Best Bets
give me give me one second here
because
what are you doing
you're a Cowboys fan everyone who's
betting the Eagles right now and like is
getting like this this is
the Cowboys fan wearing Eagles gears
look at this look at this every
quarterback if every quarterback in the
league became a free agent today I would
give Jalen hurts a mega max deal this
team this team is the best team in all
of football this may or may have
something to do with the fact that the
loser has to eat the world's hottest
Pizza of this game but this is tough to
watch
I agree it'll be tough to watch Greg eat
that pizza I 100 agree with you but
Jalen hurts if he did not get hurt at
the end of the season was The Runaway
favorite to win and run away he was like
minus 120. you're lost it was run away
it wasn't even close it was that's what
we call Value Sam minus 120 in my head
he was minus 7.50 okay they win in the
trenches they have the best offensive
line in football their running game is
incredible you talk about the 49ers
running game
49ers allow an average of 70 rushing
yards per game is this
is your best bet or is it mine what are
we doing here this is Eagles Eagles
Eagles I'm done with the 49ers
propaganda better running game better
offensive line big play slay is gonna
what better running game
running game
not today maybe maybe when they're
playing the Giants not today against
that 49ers Rush defense yes the 49ers
brush defense is going to be clamping
that up uh
Ryan just threw me on the loop Ryan just
threw me Ryan let's review the picks
from today uh Before We Say Goodbye
let's review the picks and then you know
what we're going to tell them to do
you go about the Eagles
no see oh you messed up the Vibes bro
I don't think I did that I don't think
we we were doing it the whole day you
know we were doing screenshots
screenshot and then I tell you to like
do it I tee you up for it and you talk
about betting the Eagles
that well every show you go two on one
let's get back on the same page for the
parlay let's bring the Vibes back up
we've had a great season boys
yeah yeah I mean eight and three
definitely a great season yeah for sure
all right so the first one illusion
record for the season
you talking about bringing the Vibes
back up why are you
pretty that's true if I fought my phone
my fault
it was barely above 500 by the way
um okay Eagles 49ers same game parlay
first leg Debo Samuel alternate rushing
yards 15 plus AJ Brown uh 80 plus
receiving yards George Kittle anytime
touchdown three legs plus 575 then we
roll over to the next game screenshot it
though screenshot there we go screenshot
uh
a second game uh Bengals Chiefs Isaiah
Pacheco over 44 and a half rushing yards
uh bath Ave boy leg remember that uh
Second One Jamar Chase over 99 and a
half receiving yards and then Travis
Kelsey anytime touchdown plus 525 or
anytime touchdown boost is Christian
McCaffrey
boosted the plus 150 on DraftKings
screenshot it and then
Our Best Bets Greg 49ers moneyline
Sam has a 49ers future which
I do too uh you were a frog you were a
frog
calling him the best team in the league
when you just couldn't yeah his future
where you bet again you've been on the
Seahawks you've been on the Cowboys and
you've been on the East like some some
Niners future you have yeah
yeah more money on the Niners future
than the money I placed on them to lose
that's it you just don't want to eat the
pizza usually yeah yeah I don't want any
pizza Duck Pizza that pizza
Ryan and I are going Head to Head today
the loser has to eat the world's hottest
Pizza make sure you guys follow us on BR
betting on all social platforms you guys
will not not be entertained you guys how
you like you like how I use that double
negative right there not not hey we'll
be back we'll be back Super Bowl week
with a lot of fun for you my name is
Greg Ivory next to me is the man I like
to call the man the myth the legend Sam
Richmond and next to him is a fraud
we're signing out
great way to sign off
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]